pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing
company dedicated to making the very
best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6 built to
wear
not to wear out visit grip6.com
pogchimps
[Music]
playing with the white pieces in this
first game and she has a very unique
opening i don't know if you have heard
of this opening cutie it's called the
bird's opening when you push the f
pawn at the very start to f4 she's
playing so
you're playing fast holy moly
they're both playing fast they're both
over the 10 minute mark
i don't mind that oh she missed it
i i think oh yeah sorry i i was seeing
it uh
with a bit of a time difference uh she
hasn't noticed yet that the bishop on f5
is hanging the rook could take it she's
attacking the the rook on a8 but now if
the rook moves
that will attack the bishop on bf7
what do you think he moves the rook
that's a good move now both bishops are
hanging
and queen trade we love one of those
um
why
oh interesting oh no nico
didn't spot the hanging it's gonna be
it's gonna be trade fiesta
bishop is hanging wait i have a free
check
oh they both just have don't know
bishops out there
living their best life bishop to d4
check by myth is a really strong move
because
he could take the bishop of nico for
free
yes check me
checkmate uh maybe not jackman just yet
but the bishop the bishop is hanging
oh
uh oh
the realization that two of which is
regarding this we had no
clue and now after capturing the pawn on
a7 she has a past pawn that a3 pawn
could be a potential queen but it's
still f for
from promotion the evaluation bar has
jumped but i don't think this is obvious
what
what's going on um the knight
is now on a square that is disconnecting
the black bishop from from that pond
there's the pawn she's nico's been
staring at that pond for the last few
moves
true ever since you mentioned that she
had that bishop of capture with the
rooks hanging i think she has seen it
too
now this is tough for myth because
suddenly
he is down upon he was up upon and the
past two moves
he lost two pawns excellent yeah the
thought process
that the right one that's exactly the
right one because you need to try to
stop the pawn with the rook
but then the knight will be in trouble
so that's why this
rook move by nico earlier pinning the
knight was a great decision
and i think she knows it that now her
position oh
miss is attacking both the rook and the
bishop but the rook on b2
was unprotected now it's a full rook up
for nico
oh poor myth um he fought very well but
eventually the experience of
nico has decided i think some of the
most critical moments when everything
was hanging nico kept her
cool and calculated better okay so
looking at this
nico still has seven whole minutes
i don't understand how she's so fast
is anna
great perfect this is
this is awesome um
anna looks lovely and i'm totally cut
out for
this and you guys are enjoying
yourselves and we're having a good time
and nico is gonna take this w she's just
gonna laddermate
any second now
myth is gonna fight it at this point
this is when everyone in chat spams very
toxically and they tell you to resign
but nico's got it that feels good
and we are back hey cutie how's it going
good
nothing has changed you saved chess from
their worst nightmare which was me
representing them alone
so happy to have you here i'm gonna be
honest i watch you on chess tv all the
time and you're fantastic so i don't
think it's so nice
there's no saving needed
[Laughter]
just all of the chat's hair they're just
pulling it out
well we do have central control by myth
and
nico moving quickly she typically does
so she plays really fast
she does and i i wonder she said
before like sometimes she just feels
like she needs to move and that helps
her chest
she's gained a lot of rating throughout
this pogchamps she's up to 872. she
started i think
in the 500s well nico is going for an
aggressive plan with c5 striking the
center
and the engine bar just jumped up here
and it's because white can continue
taking space with a pawn push to e5 but
it's very natural that myth would take
the pawn i think that's our
first instinct okay pawn has been taken
by myth
and now that bar drops but it's so
tricky because
when you're playing you obviously don't
have the bar and even while watching it
may not be clear
but a large reason why is this bishop on
e3 normal developing move
this knight can come to g4 and this
bishop on g7
is the best piece on the board i think
he
will take the blame as any good coach
should yeah i do think you are
learning things and well nico she's
striking here with a5 she's pushing all
of her pieces forward
and i don't think that myth has a plan
so actually when you look at this
position
what are some ideas that you can see
here i mean if i were myth
i would start moving my knights his
knights need to get out there playing
somehow
am i crazy no no but he just
lost his bishop for a pawn there he oh
took there and
the bishop was captured so i think he's
really sad for him i thought it was free
and ended up not being the case
the b4 square not very well defended but
also
nico has more time she started with
niko's amazing
with time it blows my mind i mean she's
just
too fast and she honestly maybe there
should be a bullet tournament
with all you getting one minute on the
clock i think she could win it
oh okay so using your idea though to get
the bishop out
but could drop in 94. yeah i think we're
just going to lose that night
well that's just a trade i suppose
correct well
a pawn was taken and oh the engine did
not like that move so the big issue
and she just took a knight on c3 is that
this king
has been out in the open so actually
just a move ago queen out to b6 check
puts this king in a world of hurt but
knight 63 you can't complain about that
as
she took a piece and she still is up
material and
he just doesn't have any pieces
remaining so i guess at a certain point
he can shuffle and he needs to be
careful because
now this pawn is under attack in
addition to the check
he's been checked again yeah interesting
uh-huh and he moves king up so that was
really smart because if
this pawn had been captured uh let's say
you make this move and the pawns
captured you also lose your
queen at the end of the line so he was
smart to
make the move that he did king up and he
comes the queen
so is nico just going to keep pinning
trying to get that queen is that
i think that's what she's going to try
to do yeah she gave the check to
she can just trade queens and then win
the end game
and bring her king up and then moving
her pawns
she is our queen i've said it i've said
it
so now you're yes she's yours she's
yours too
we live in this state you and i the
state of chess.com and we decide who our
queen is and it is nico today
okay and by we decide you mean i decide
okay god i just want to make sure we
didn't even say in that yes
yes absolutely we're on the same page
because chad has decided that you are
their queen though it seems
oh i'm not deserving of such an honor i
voted for nico chad voted for hess
i guess hess will wear the crown today
he has a little more votes
i suppose oh well i guess we have to do
a poll
to see what they really think right it's
the only way through true
true run the numbers
yeah we're data people here and it's
running
this pawn is running queen is happening
i think nico
has us under control the only question i
have is will she have more than 10
minutes when the game ends
i hope so
i'll be interested to see where did how
many matches has niko won this will be
her first
yes of your first match win that'll
awesome awesome awesome awesome
but be careful about the sail mate okay
the king has one move
so it wasn't stalemate and now the king
has some space but that was
actually pretty close she's making a
third queen
i hope so she's playing with her food
but be careful not to stalemate when you
have too many queens you could
accidentally allow your opponent
to get a stalemate
just make sure no mercy no mercy me
nico i almost said mikko uh-oh freudian
slip wow
no one tell mika i'm thinking about her
it's okay she must shoot off into space
yeah mars oh
one point's gone that was interesting
myth was so confused
said what there it is oh
there it is there's the finale two
nothing for nico and myth was just
absolutely startled by the queen can i
can i take that he probably shouldn't
have taken it would have given him
better stalemate chances yeah that's a
good point
nico first off congrats how does it feel
to score your first dub
um it feels good um i really
was feeling a little down because i was
like i really did lose
to little boy benji and then
a french dude named chasardosh so i was
like
i need to get some kind of win and
luckily
myth was like hey i'm gonna let niko win
and i was like
nice a silver platter
on a silver platter here yeah
well cutie's cat was rooting for you
miss he is my cat
oh my gosh really would you say hi to my
son please
he's
let's go i have one finally but i'm the
biggest nico simp
so nice split household crazy
so she did great today yeah i mean nico
so you were playing really quickly did
you just we're feeling it today i mean
what was your mindset going in
uh taking on myth in this matchup i mean
i wasn't i wasn't uh far from
myths elo reading like three weeks ago
and
i just got back into like grinding chess
and i feel like i've already been
playing for
like over a year so i kind of already
knew
what the mindset is at that elo so i
feel like i had like an advantage there
um and and yeah so so
i was i kind of already was in myth
shoes not too long ago
so i feel like i already had like an
advantage
in that sense she said that elo
how do you feel about that myth that evo
dude
i feel like i it wasn't even a battle
today then dude i
stepped into nico's world that's what
happened today exactly
i stepped dude is anybody here watching
juicy kaizen
she just pulled you know she pulled out
her realm and engulfed me at it
that's what happened today i didn't know
what i was getting into
you